THEY WERE SUPPOSED TO HAVE AN
IPO2018.
THAT'S NOT GOING TO HAPPEN SO
YOU TRY TO DIG THE HOLE DEEPER.
YOU HAVE TO COME UP WITH TWO
TOPICS.
CNN SPENT MOST OF THE WEEK
DETAILING A WHITE TRUCK THEY
BELIEVE PRESIDENT TRUMP SENT TO
KEEP THE MEDIA FROM WATCHING HIM
GOLF AT MARLA GO.
>> NOT THAT WE CAN PROVE THE
PRESIDENT IS THERE BECAUSE A BOX
TRUCK BLOCKED REPORTERS.
>> WHAT'S UP WITH BLOCKING THE
GOLF SWING?
>> IMAGES OF PRESIDENT TRUMP ON
THE GOLF COURSE.
>> THIS TRUCK SHOWED UP OUT OF
NOWHERE.
WE DON'T KNOW WHERE IT CAME
FROM.
NOT ONLY DO THE TWEETS PROGRAM
WAS IN THE BOX TRUCK?
TWO SCROOPS OF ICE CREAM OR DIET
COKES.
MAYBE THAT SHOULD BE THE
INVESTIGATION?
CNN IS NOT THE NETWORK IT ONCE
ISIS BEING DECIMATED IN IRAQ AND
SYRIA.
THEY LOST 98% OF THEIR
TERRITORY.
THEY HAVE LESS THAN A THOUSAND
FIGHTERS NOW.
I DON'T SEE COVERAGE ON THAT,
AND I SEE CRAP, AND IT IS CRAP,
FOCUS FROM A ONCE PROUD NETWORK
THAT SHOULDN'T BE COVERING THIS
SORT OF STUFF.
IT'S RIDICULOUS.
>> THEY HAVE AN AGENDA.
THEY ARE OBSESSED WITH
DESTROYING THEM.
SCARE
WIKILEAKS STORY, DONALD TRUMP
HAD INFORMATION TEN DAYS BEFORE
EVERYONE ELSE, ALREADY IN THE
THEY SHOULD REVEAL WHO THE
SOURCE WAS.
THE SOURCE WAS PURPOSELY PUTTING
OUT FALSE INFORMATION, HOWEVER
THE WASHINGTON POST ASKED FOR
DOCUMENT EVIDENCE TO SEE IF
I THINK JAKE DOES GOOD STUFF.
>> WE SAW DAVE BRIGGS ON THERE
AS WELL.
THEY HAVE GOOD PEOPLE THERE.
WHEN THEY KEEP DOING STORIES
LIKE THIS, IT DESTROYS THE ONCE
PROUD NETWORK, FOCUS ON NEWS,
AND STOP FOCUSING ON TAKING DOWN
A PRESIDENT.
>> WILL THERE BE LESS ANTI-TRUMP
AND MORE BALANCE ON THE TWO,
KNOCKING HIM DOWN WHEN THEY
THINK HE'S WRONG BUT NOTE THE
ECONOMY, THE TAXES, SEE MORE OF
A BALANCE?
>> TOOTH PASTE IS OUT OF THE
TUBE.
WE ARE DOWN THE PATH.
CNN MADE A BUSINESS DECISION TO
GO NEGATIVE ON PRESIDENT TRUMP.
THE PROBLEM IS, THEY LOST
>> JOE, NICE OF YOU TO COME IN
ON THIS BEAUTIFUL FRIDAY.
>> IT'S GORGEOUS OUT.